si es son 20 votos electorales santiago
los que se reparten en el estado de
pensilvania y se están contando con
mucho cuidado por eso precisamente que
explicaba es de ese equipo de donald
tram la familia e incluso el abogado
personal del mandatario se desplazaron
ayer hasta pensilvania para intentar
detener ese recuento de votos es muy
interesante santiago porque mientras que
el presidente trata de detener el conteo
de votos
sus seguidores precisamente lo que
quieren es que siga avanzando porque en
este estado donald trump tiene una
ventaja muy justa de tan sólo dos puntos
poco a poco se va reduciendo hace pocos
minutos hemos escuchado a la jefa de
campaña del equipo de joe biden que
decía que tienen las esperanzas altas en
este estado tienen una ventaja y la
ventaja es para donald trump pero ellos
confían en que el voto por correo les
pueda ayudar y es que ese voto por
correo que se ha contado ahora el 77 77
por ciento de estos votos van a parar al
demócrata así que muy pendientes porque
estamos también a la espera de que el
gobernador de pensilvania dé una
actualización
estos datos exactos me llama la atención
que precisamente en pensilvania donde
aparentemente estaría ganando donald
trump a sí mismo pida un recuento de los
votos vamos a georges y ámame en todos
los ojos están puestos también en este
estado uno de los cinco que faltan por
confirmar ganador podemos esperar para
esta noche los resultados así pues así
lo acaba de anunciar la secretaria de
estado que esta noche podríamos conocer
esos resultados santiago georgia ha sido
un estado tradicionalmente republicano
allí donald trump también lleva una
ventaja muy ajustada de cerca de 18.000
votos únicamente así que esto podría
cambiar en cualquier momento en esta
rueda de prensa al equipo de bailén
también decía que se sienten optimistas
que saben que están muy reñidos pero que
confían que puedan remontar confían
también en esos votos que faltan todavía
por recontar y que al parecer proceden
de las zonas más demócratas de este
estado como podría ser atlanta otro de
los estados claves mamen que podría
definir los comicios carolina del norte
no las estimaciones muestran a donald
trump como el triunfador pero con un
margen muy share
esto es así de nuevo seguimos
efectivamente con esos márgenes muy
ajustados que por eso están alargándose
tanto estas elecciones aquí donald trump
tiene una ventaja de 76 mil votos de
nuevo el presidente juega en casa
carolina del norte ha sido un estado
tradicionalmente republicano en las
últimas 10 elecciones ha ganado el
partido republicanos salvo en 2000 2008
con el presidente barack obama así que
los demócratas continúan con las
esperanzas de que esto pueda volver a
ocurrir pero ojo santiago porque en este
estado se pueden contar votos por correo
que lleguen hasta el día 12 de noviembre
siempre que tengan fecha anterior al día
3 así que en este estado han dicho que
podría tardar en conocerse los
resultados finales hasta el 13 de
noviembre aquí a los demócratas confían
en el voto afroamericano que representa
un 30 por ciento de la población y por
supuesto de nuevo en el voto por correo
que tradicionalmente está demostrado que
está favoreciendo a los demócratas